feel good hey everyone welcome to
today's podcast don't forget to tell
your friends follow us on spotify
or subscribe to us on apple podcast
listen to us every tuesday on podcast
one or
anywhere you like to listen to podcast
what is up amanda and bosh in the house
we got a special guest today
oh my god a special guest on feels good
who's already making me feel so
good i think i'm okay
i guess in today's episode we'll be
talking about newly released
gaming councils how your work week could
get shorter
the best time to have sex and so much
more oh
someone got excited the best time to
have sex yeah
the day time oh really
isn't it a nighttime thing you never
know we're changing
we'll we'll get there guys we'll get
there sorry yeah okay yeah
i love how i love how we just jumped
right into it like right now when you're
like
uh yeah someone started popping
someone got really excited yeah it's not
really a surprise
but we have a celebrity guest for all of
you
he is a social media star you're a
celebrity too
you're the guest oh yeah yeah but you're
the guest you're our first celebrity
guys
oh he is our first
yeah that's so cool you're the first
oh ever but you're the first ever good
[Laughter]
well i can just i don't have to read
this um so
he is social media king turned
actor starring in babysitter two which
came out really during that too
now i got to see oh my god i loved that
film both of you guys in that film that
was awesome
yeah i could watch yeah i would watch
that again yeah you guys are so good
then um also holiday just came out
you're in that sneaker heads
killed it stole the scene in every
episode every part of the episode
killed it killed it oh thank you you
know you did i did okay
you're amazing andy's humble what's this
why your mic not out
oh because i'm using this mic
[Laughter]
wait what are you what are you guys
seeing what are you guys seeing
we just saw a masked man which is very
good by the way a guy just
walked by in the background
who was the master did you see that bye
no
oh
[Applause]
sorry guys you guys saw someone across
your computer
no oh
okay hold on one sec
you'll be able to hear anything right
that you're grabbing it oh
yeah no you're coming hey guys i'm
calling in for help um it's
more wine where are you at yeah wait let
me show you
oops this is like where we're staying
um it's like we're basically staying
where like the dalai lama lives
on darumshala so there's like loads of
monks and monasteries and like
meditation centers
and like it's stunning it's super pretty
um yeah so i can't wait to bring you
guys here at some point
i know
so oh speaking of like batch again
since you know he's here since i'm the
special guest
since he's a special guest he also
owns a lot of different businesses you
have glove works which i've been to
it's an amazing gym lots of boxing kills
me
oh wow crawling out what was that
i love boxing oh yeah so you have to
come next time you're in l.a
yes in la right yep and then anywhere
else yet
la um new york and
santa monica what you have three
different student like boxing studios
yeah well that's it for really
that's amazing wow
and then he also has a nano mask yup
nano air mask
which two are those yeah started that
during the pandemic
you have face masks oh yeah dude
you're so entertaining oh my god that's
amazing yeah it's talk about like being
entrepreneurial yes i love it
i love it when people have that side as
well this is
entrepreneurial isn't it hard
or enterprising oh there you go that's
there we go
oh let's take a look at your masks voila
very effective wow are they like super
comfy okay you know what i'm starting to
love as well it's like the masks with
the little chains
on them so that when you bring them down
you don't because i keep losing mine
yeah i lose mine everywhere yeah
yeah so just like little yeah so it's
like they're kind of like sunglasses
what are those just playing with
everything
and yeah so speaking of businesses
that we own and being entrepreneurial we
have the 66 wine
which we're doing right now
cheers wait wait a second that is your
wine
yeah that is so cool guys
oh my god okay so wait where is your
vineyard
good wait let me get that in summerland
you guys wait wait bush open i like hold
up that wine bottle again
i burnt my finger on the candle oh yeah
because i
signed a waiver before you entered is
this for like aesthetics
yes actually you can move it over i just
said it because
that is so cool i didn't know you guys
had a wine well how long did it take you
guys to make that
um well we started we started working on
it and like
when was it may yeah and then we came
out with it on
june 26th you guys started working on it
during quarantine
yeah because we were like we're drinking
wine a lot we love wine let's make our
own wine and we tasted all these
different wines from the vineyard
and then we just picked their favorites
they all have 91 plus
ratings on the wine which is incredible
for wine
like i don't know if we can send to
india but you'll just have to come i got
you
try okay i just and like bring 20 back
with me
but like but why 6 26
that's our birthday june 26th
both you guys have the same birthday
yeah when's your birthday oh my god
11th august so like nowhere close to 6
26.
oh but if we did a collaboration if we
did a collaboration we could do 6
26 11 26
11. if there's some numbers thing going
on there we'll work it out
6 36 8. well that's august 6 26
august no i'm telling you what do you
have a good story from us when
we were making the wine yeah tell us
everything about making your
little wine journey tell me about us uh
trying to come up with the name remember
well
that was all you no that wasn't me that
was my friend
yeah but you you came to me with you
you're okay for me that's you
oh yeah that was yeah
what a story bad we both had the same
birthday
um we both had the same birthday and
it was just right in front of our faces
it was like june 26th
and then those numbers like you have
1942 oh which yeah
like would always yeah we'd always drink
1942 yeah how do you get in the numbers
game
yeah six two six twenties yeah that's a
great and i love how like it's like
six and then twenty-six like it's like
numbers and
um alphabets that's so cool and letters
yeah it's like a nice little mix and
it's a pretty bottle
oh yeah yeah we got so many bottles so
so wait are you guys stalking all over
the states
um right now it's direct to consumer and
i think about 35 of the states i want to
say
because it's just different laws with
shipping so okay right now we're working
on expanding but we
just started on june 20. you guys stock
in
north carolina south carolina south
carolina good
maybe we'll get someone to drive out
there
yeah all right no i'm going to say why
is that where you is that where you're
going to be
no my sister lives there and she loves
wine really she loves
yeah so i'm so going to send her some
yay
oh she has to give us like a solid
review and let us know like honest
honestly everyone loves it honestly
everyone's like oh my god
like i have something okay so wait what
is it what is it what's the what's the
speciality like what does it taste
what is the taste huh what's the taste
jose
it has like um we have a rose we have a
pinot we have a cab
and we have um sauvignon blanc we
yeah so and the rose is my favorite
though
i like the pinot a lot a lot of people
like the pinot the rose is more of like
um
crisp strawberry notes in it
it's really good and it's amazing it's
like
stella's body but it's light enough it's
like it's perfect
because people who are new to wine can
enjoy it too but
yeah people that are love wine or can
drink it and they're like oh this is
like a nice
easy to drink wine and effective very
efficient
i amanda i've been like we've been doing
our podcast for so long and talking
about so many things
you never told me you started a whine
like this never came up just back really
amanda
i was waiting for this moment and now
but like really really casually she
started drinking it last week and i was
like oh
and like because it's super like it's
morning for me so i like have coffee and
it's funny because she has
chamomile tea and just last week she she
switched to wine she's like i'm on my
first glass and she was
i know in my second class it's my new
it's my new um
cheers six two six chairs
well it's our saying is time is a fickle
thing
yes oh oh oh but why it is though
six two six two six it's a number which
is time and time is the
fickle thing it's just like a silly
thing so i love it
enjoying time because you got to enjoy
every moment and it's also a fun poetic
scene that
reminds me of alice in wonderland yep oh
oh did she use that did she say time's
difficult
yeah she said the best things in that in
that cartoon she really did
it's on the back we have a whole poem on
the back of the bottle yeah oh
that is so cool wow you guys
what was your week like um well for me
i've been just like
i've been drinking sweets
kind of like collide and are one now
they blend together
yeah but you've been working a lot
you've been doing a lot of music lately
yeah too yeah every day in the studio
trying to pump this 626.
oh you put it oh wait can i say yeah
yeah okay you put in a song too
the name of the wine and one of his new
songs also
so great like is music any chance i get
i just
say it yeah i love it is music a new
thing for you
yeah starting quarantine oh my how many
things did you start in quarantine
like i feel so bad i feel like i haven't
like done anything except release them
yet
you haven't seen it yeah i never faced
them yet
okay well when when are you going to be
releasing your music um
maybe in like a month or so oh
nice so how many songs have you got
there um
i don't i've done 30 since since uh
quarantine
jeez i didn't even know that's the
pretty soft
yeah talk about being productive
[Applause]
oh my god i'm feeling so terrible about
myself i feel like i didn't do
anything in corinth what are you talking
about you're out there filming from
morning until night in until like
2 a.m during the day but like this is
that quarantine's over now like during
quarantine like literally all i did
was like sit around and like attempt to
read books or like fake read books
i i was fake reading i was yeah um
and uh because i couldn't get through it
i was just like i was just sitting at
home and i was doing like a little bit
of cooking and just
really kind of doing nothing and loving
it and
you know playing with my cats and that
was it like i didn't i didn't like have
a grand
you know like business idea
or anything but the minute quarantine
finished though i jumped straight back
into work like
you know i've been like super busy since
then but during quarantine for like
a couple of months i think like a good
five six months i just
sat around i still didn't do much i know
i didn't do anything
i i want to know how i mean that's fine
though you need a break
too like you're you go non-stop and then
you just need a moment where you can
just like
you know it's like me when i i go and
visit my family and stuff it like resets
my mind and then when you go back to
work you're even more creative and oh
yeah
even more fun do you ever do that i used
to
but then no anymore travel to home
in my mind oh man yes i'm in a constant
mission ladies and gentlemen oh wait do
you meditate though
it really ends up like are you gonna
quiz you know
i'm like um what did you say about
meditation
yeah i did i used to um in my in my
school
we had to we had a class and it was uh
we used to meditate in class
yeah what in what school uh new york
film academy
oh of course how long ago was that no
but now i've done it so much i'm in a
constant state of meditation
is that enlightenment what is that what
it sound like yeah i mean
yeah when you reach nirvana have you
reached marijuana
you hair you look folks like you're a
nirvana right now
that's how he started so many companies
and has thirties
he's so enlightened that you know
obviously
i'm not even sitting right now i'm
floating he's levitating
he's levitating i think that's a good
example though of enjoying what you do
and then like because you genuinely
enjoy everything that you do
oh yeah like in anything yeah don't
enjoy you
hire somebody or you can like have
somebody else handle that part
that you don't enjoy doing so you kind
of like facilitate and you're like all
right here you go
you delegate you're just like you do
that you do that i'll focus on this
because this is where i'm happy
yeah i think that's the easiest way to
do things and it keeps you stress free
yeah and it keeps you in a concert
taking notes of meditating
no like it's it's no no it's it's so
good though
i'm so like happy that you do that
because and it's true like
actors need to meditate and a lot of
like the really really good actors that
i know here
um who do like theater and who like a
lot of like character actors
they are meditating twice a day for 45
minutes each
you know at a time and they are like
because it's there's so much focus
and like you know you're so centered
when you meditate and that's what it is
about acting as well you got to be in
the moment at every single given time
meditation i think helps you do that so
um
yeah it's so important and i know like
on days that i haven't meditated or if
like i've really like not meditated for
some time
everything just becomes kind of
confusing so i want to reach that point
you know that you are in where you're
just like in a constant state of it
i mean i've never heard that
from india right yeah he does this
yeah i was doing a tick tock with um
with uh a dp no
i can't remember who who are you talking
to talk to
from india and she made me do this i
think that was the dt
was it yeah
because i think i did something but she
made me she made me do this and then say
he like has a saying or something
like singing a song he's like yeah he
has yeah exactly he's like
he's whenever he's in a song or like in
the middle of a song when he needs to
strike a pose
he like he goes to that or like when
he's like on stage
like he just needs to stand there and
then just go
and the whole crowd is like yeah why
it's it's it's basically like when it's
like the eyebrow
uh or or it's even like when michael
jackson used to like come on stage
and he just used to stand there and just
do that one signature thing like with
his like his pelvic
dress like it was like that one
signature and all the girls and everyone
was like
oh my god thank you
oh yes are we talking about what
we're talking well batch just jumped
right on to it
those are interesting i think i think i
think we want to
of this podcast right now which is you
know when you mentioned
the time of day yeah i think he's just
like been itching
yeah yeah like it shows where the
interest is
we have to i don't even know when it is
it's in our fun facts we gotta get to it
really quick when did you did you always
know
that you could sing or you could rap
like was it always something that you
knew you could do
no i just wanted to try it to have fun
and then
it came out pretty good so i was like oh
yeah i want to try it
and then how do you feel about your
performance
i feel like it's amazing i feel like
that might be the next drape
i think you are the next one
that's the bottle opener so oh my gosh
for when we finish this bottle we have
this have you seen this jacqueline
no whitney cummings shout out when
incomings um so you press the button and
you turn it on
now it's on i'll let you do it i want to
do it and then you put it down on
the 666 bumper
[Music]
that is a moon
who invented this i don't know let me
see oh my gosh
like like this the quirk like raised
itself up right over
his face and his eyes were like how much
is this
i don't know like it was a gift i wanted
to invest you just have to go to whitney
cummings house
how do we invest how do we make a 66
wine version yes oh yeah
oh my gosh there it goes crazy mind
again
the mind of an entrepreneur i'm telling
you
wants to buy everything you've also been
gaming a lot
in quarantine yeah or what do we call i
just call everything quarantined now
long was wait a minute how long was your
quarantine
because like there has been so much
yeah april for every march april
i don't even yeah oh and then it turned
into social distancing and back to like
quarantining
and i don't know like yeah now
everyone's into strip clubs
back to the strip joint because it's
true
it's a pendant it's a pandemic
that was good um you've been gaming a
lot are you doing it are you streaming
that are you just doing it for fun just
doing it for fun
that's not very entrepreneurial i know
but but wait we had we had a fact about
gaming i think last week or the week
before
that it actually makes you a lot more
creative or productive
remember they were saying like doctors
should be gaming or something
apparently it makes you product it makes
you productive even though like at that
point you don't seem very productive but
creatively or you know it makes you
productive isn't that crazy
yeah that's great maybe that's why
you're so productive and creative
i love sudoku yeah so good the more
but even more but that is product but it
is productive though
yeah yeah and it's like math kind of
well you guys
you've seen all that stuff going on with
like the um the ps5
and the xbox what is it xbox five or
xbox
x because i've been debating yes player
but xbox been trying to bribe me lately
they sent me an xbox for free told me
all i do is
put a little swipe up link no i'm giving
that thing away
oh great
so what are you playing i mean like is
xbox i thought xbox was the thing to
play
xbox i'm so confused for like
people that are hmm how do i say this
homeless
and the playstation wait a minute
did playstation sponsor you no
he's an entrepreneur oh i didn't know i
didn't know playstation xbox were two
different things
yeah playstation there's like a whole
beef between like playstation players
and xbox players
oh my god so wait what would you say
that's like the perfect gift what's like
the perfect gift someone's giving you
then like
i could see um
i don't know i know a really good gift
that batch gave me before
what what um it was
the beyonce concert oh yeah ah
you did go to the beach wow you took her
to a concert and that was when the
lemonade
album came out wow
yeah and i saw her live as well vip
tickets
front row we saw beyonce we were so
close we could see beyonce's leg hairs
yeah i was like and there weren't i love
it
there weren't even even there weren't
because she's perfect she's a goddess
yeah she is a guy she's a goddess
she is a goddess like hair is being
politically correct right now
yeah yeah like it's okay if she has like
yeah it's fine like i'll start growing
hair like
she has her there yeah
but yeah that was one of my favorite
gifts you don't have a favorite gift
that somebody gave you yeah
no one gives me anything i want things i
sent you something before
and you don't even remember what it was
it was that good and then i sent it
and then you didn't you didn't even know
it was from me i sent it okay what was
it
chocolate your perfect gift it was your
perfect gift
yeah you just did something that i just
don't remember it it was what i remember
no it was not something she'd actually
talk about she's not like that amanda
but like you know she doesn't like to
brag but it was
your perfect gift it's just that you are
not focusing right now you're not you're
not in your mind
exactly you sent me halle berry yes
and she knocked on the door and you
didn't answer oh
so yeah you are lost you're lost
what is the perfect
[Music]
what about you jacqueline what have you
gotten that you just like stood out to
you
oh like like a perfect gift
memorable i guess uh
like a perfect i don't know i somehow i
feel like when my
like whenever my dad or my mom gives me
something it's like
like my dad ends up doing this thing
where he gifts me
like on my birthday or like christmas or
something like he'll always give me like
a piece of jewelry
and it's like it's always like a very
similar piece but he'll be like
he'll wrap it up real nice and there's
like so much thought that's gone into it
i know he's like specifically gone and
like he's
looked for it and he's chosen the piece
and then he'll buy even though it's my
birthday he'll buy my mom and my sister
the exact same piece
so it's like every single year like we
have the exact same piece of jewelry
i find it super cute you know because
it's like it's just
i i think it's so thoughtful when they
go and buy something it comes like from
such a special place and
yeah so they like he could like
literally give me anything and i'd be
like oh
dad it's always the thought
like i for girls at least because batch
doesn't remember the gift i got him
nothing he wants to know the best time
of day for sex like right yeah
all
right
can we just skip to that right now why
are we talking about i mean i may as
well
like here we go should we just jump on
oh are you
are you there yes
all right did you know an average
woman's
orgasm lasts 20 seconds 20 seconds
to a man's five-second orgasm 20 seconds
that's crazy
i mean we we go through a lot every
month
i think yeah at least give us those
20-second orgasms
yeah give us something guys orgasm for
20 seconds
you guys get five seconds
[Laughter]
that's why they always go to sleep after
[Music]
but so do you guys huh
you guys always go to sleep after yeah
they do oh yeah
oh guys yeah like food
and naps and all of the above
[Laughter]
why are you looking so confused all
right well i see this thing
warner music oh you can't read it oh
it's oh you're reading it's a pandemic
so
we're sharing
[Applause]
all right and i got rapid cover test so
we're fine
disclaimer random fun facts number two
warner music owns the copyrights to
happy birthday
so it's technically oh it's
so it's technically owed royalties every
time you sing it to someone
on their big day um but
we don't i mean like happy birthday
to you yeah how does it
is it like um a hindi
version of happy birthday or is it happy
birthday
it's happy birthday i don't know
actually it's very happy version to
happy birthday
i said in india do this thing uh-huh
happy birthday
yeah but there is
oh no
yes let's just skip this one okay
moving on do you know the best
time for sex after a workout
this is due to the increased flow of
blood to the genitals
[Music]
oh best time of switches after homework
are people are so tired yeah
maybe it's like after a warm-up or maybe
a warm-up
is have sex take a break and then have
more sex because the first sex
is the it's a workout
oh my god and then better after the
first sex
exactly look at this guy yeah i mean
like they're just so creative and genius
when it comes to
yep sex yeah i mean i love that he
solves it
for everyone now you guys don't have to
work out you're two rounds of sex now
well it depends on the type of sex
you're having whether or not you can
work out after
today's episode is brought to you by
clorox when it counts
trust clorox the same way we trust
essential workers to provide the care
they give to us
families trust clorox to give them a
safe and protected home
our community heroes trust clarks to
keep places like hospitals and grocery
stores disinfected
so i know i too can trust clorox to
provide
my home with a safe environment at home
we can all enjoy
that is why i trust clorox regular
bleach by
mixing one third cup of clorox regular
bleach
with one gallon of water when used as
directed
on hard non-porous surfaces it kills
99.9 percent of germs and bacteria
on a variety of surfaces from our
kitchen floors
to the counters to the bathroom tubs of
course
laundry whites i know i can count on
clorox disinfecting products to give
myself
and my family the best home we deserve
so i have a story for you amanda
um with clorox there's one thing i
definitely use it for
every single time before i step into my
vanity van
i love the entire place disinfected
because that's where i keep my makeup
that's where i get ready that's where my
clothes are that's sometimes where i
take a nap as well
so you know i can use it all over like
the floors the countertops like any kind
of appliances over there door handles
and of course this is the time of need
so um
yeah it's been really really it just
keeps everything super clean and i feel
super safe
for me it's important to share with
loved ones and
the public in general how they can give
the most care for their loved ones
because especially during times like
these i mean
with the pandemic going on with kova
going on it's just great to be
extra sanitary with all the items that
are around you
caring for others and you know just
wiping down the door handle after you
use the bathroom or wipe it down so
important the toilet the toilet handle
don't forget the toilet handle so
keep it clean care for others care for
yourself
and use clorox so remember
when it counts trust clorox feel
good um all right
workout after
women are more prone to cheating during
ovulation than any other time of the
month
the reason behind this is the innate
tendency of human beings to reproduce
during their fertile phase therefore as
women ovulate their desire to get their
eggs
fertilized increases oh so it's an
ovulate
that's like the period right yeah
obviously
right before no no so uh yeah i mean
right before
so it's it's when you're when the egg is
ready
and like ready to get fertilized the
period is when the egg dies and it's
like it hasn't fertilized so it's just
like okay
and that's just good
that's yeah that's a nice way of putting
it but yeah that's i mean not a nice way
of putting it
oh wow oh yeah that's when they can get
pregnant the most
right well of you like well
right ovulation not on that period right
before yes right before
that's crazy right before right before
it dies i know yeah but that's like the
best
well that's when you feel like cheating
the most apparently
there's just you want to make use of the
eggs before they go
it's like um back to what we were
talking about before with
just survival and what's it called
uh i'll leave it at that it's survival
what it's no it's um what is it called
instincts it's um what's it called
uh evil evil you know survival
instincts um so yeah like basically like
human
survival is based on reproduction
and it's like it's that strong i mean
like that's that's where i think like
all of our emotions come from
it's like it's got yeah cheers to that
survival of the fittest no but like just
the need to reproduce
has i feel created the emotion of stuff
like
love and jealousy and you know
intimacy and marriage and it's just
because the entire just
with the entire goal and aim to
reproduce
have children and continue the species
so i i sometimes feel like love it can
be a bit of an illusion
um
yeah write down those lyrics for your
next song
to bring two more together just r kelly
i mean
it's a super unromantic way of thinking
about it but like
you know it's like just like it's
literally in like
for us to just reproduce so let us let
us make them believe that there's
something more to this but like
with let's just make sure that they get
kids out of that kind of so
no i think because because human species
are aliens but those feelings
i feel are manipulated
by our hormones by our hormones yeah see
like i love you so much i want to have
your babies i love you so much and like
it's like
it's why is that what what do babies
have to do
with loving someone but it's kind of
like
for 18 years
exactly i love that
like that's a long one i love that
locking them in so moving on to our next
fun fact
yeah ten dollars in your pocket and no
debts you're wealthier than
25 of americans
that doesn't feel good oh yeah because
everyone's in debt because of college
yeah college mortgages
all that stuff by the way guys
congratulations on your new
president and madam vice president
thank you yeah amazing cheers to that
[Laughter]
coffee
[Music]
but i love the first fix yeah
first female vice president is awesome
so cool i love it i keep watching this
one clip of her
being like i'm talking oh yeah yeah i'm
talking
because she was uh during the it was the
vice presidential debate i think
yeah right and she's like i'm talking
mm-hmm
yeah i was talking and then that other
guy had a flaw in his head
just distracted from the whole thing
that slime is the most famous fly in the
world
in the history of the world crazy though
like we were talking about this on our
last episode about how like
people in india pay attention to the us
elections
and like how we don't pay attention to
oh yeah
it's like it doesn't go back i mean like
yeah but no i mean it's not even just
it's the entire world
pays attention to the us elections it's
like it's just such a
did you vote
she whispered
you have another fun fact jacqueline
i'll let you read that one
all righty i like this one
drinking red wine in small doses is
better for you than not drinking at all
red wine has antioxidants that combat
some diseases
wow oh we're gonna do well i know
but look the like the longest living
people oh my god out of the bottle
amanda
oh okay well it's a pandemic
hey
and we didn't yeah we did it and we're
not drinking it yeah yeah
we have these legal um legal rules that
we have to follow we're not allowed to
drink
we're not allowed to get wasted on it
yeah so but we still do um should get
some chips on this show
i'll add it to the shirtless
we need some sunglasses too or you can
just put your face mask on
yeah i want to go back to batch we're
jumping around a lot but it's fine
um i want to go back to batch and see
what his
mindset is and ownership of companies
and what is his goal in the
the business side of things and yeah i
believe ownership is very important
because oh yeah my friend i believe
ownership is very important because when
you own something
it's not just like yeah you can it's
like
you know you get some money here it's
cool for like a month it's cool for a
year it's cool for two years
but you want to own something so you can
have generational wealth that way you
can
pass down to your kids and their kids
and their kids and their kids
it's like um if you own a
ona the apple if you were like the
founder of apple
you owned it i owned owned it
if you own apple you'll be able to like
pass down that wealth
to your kids and your kids kids and your
kids because kids
all the babies and then are you wanting
to just fill
every type of slot
of products like to own
yes like i want to own technology i want
to own
you know yeah anything that i find
interesting anything that i can
um use my my resources
to further enhance the development
of the product i don't know what i just
said but it sounded cool
whatever you just said really
compliments what amanda just did
because it was both it was both really
clumsy
she's put liner in her boobs
what is that water i mean if you saw it
you saw it if you didn't
please don't spill the seed but okay but
i need to ask you though like i i love
getting into like all sorts of
okay
sorry
[Applause]
i have a bad habit it's not fair i want
to be in that room right now
when i laugh sometimes i um
[Music]
spit
i was moving on to okay when you
do all these like really enterprising
things and like you you have all these
businesses
where did you get time to focus on like
your acting career
or like how do you balance that like the
training that goes into it or the work
that goes into it or like
the filming like i find it so difficult
to actually give time to
to both even though i do enjoy you know
like the business side of things as well
but i find like acting demands so much
from people
it is but at the same time it's like
when when you're acting and you're
traveling
there's so much free time to do what you
need to do it's like it's an easy time
to delegate
so when i was in i was filming in lake
tahoe which is like another part of
calif
another part of california and um when i
was there
it's like yeah the hours are long but
then if i have an off day
during that off day i'm working on the
other stuff and i say okay this needs to
be done this needs to be done that needs
to be done
and then i have like a strong team i
have my sister and she's
amazing by the way oh yeah she handles
she handles business
and then she'll get what needs to be
done done
um yeah that's great i think a support
team is very important when it comes to
these things because like
i mean i am so exhausted on like on my
off days of like
in between shoots or something like i
almost find myself
wanting to find the energy to do stuff
but i i just i just can't like i just
vegetate and like i'm just like i just
have enough mind space right now to
maybe
watch something or or fake read or you
know like just
but the support team is super important
i think like if you have
like a good team that can actually put
things together for you and see your
vision the way you see it
that is you know it's impossible to do
things on your own
and i'm glad that you actually have
someone especially if it's family
yeah you're so lucky i mean business is
tricky i've been into business
i've done a few things um where i've
lost a lot of money
and uh and it's just that because i i
guess i didn't have
enough people kind of supporting me and
also i was very naive i think like when
it comes to business you've got to
remove that side of you
um and understand like how cutthroat it
could be
probably or like how professional you
need to be when it comes to business
um so yeah if you want to avoid losing
out or losing your money or losing your
savings or your investments
so now i'm starting with a completely
new slate on like everything that i want
to either invest in or start up
and um yeah but i've made i don't know
if you've made mistakes in the past with
that but
i definitely have i've like lost quite a
bit
what was one mistake that you made
jacqueline
like you don't have to like being the
guy who's there
who are you guys talking about you guys
are saying
it's 6 26. 6 26
is it 6 26 over there
it's 10 30.
[Applause]
close yeah a few hours uh mistakes that
i made
okay well again i think i never had a
proper team in place i never had a
proper legal team
um i took for granted i think maybe
just kind of presuming assuming that the
people who were handling what they were
doing
um knew what they were doing and
actually they didn't
so uh yeah i think it's important that
you have your legal team in place like
have one good lawyer who's like going
through your paperwork and making sure
that
you're taken care of if anything goes
goes wrong and even i think the most
important thing in business is
always expect things to go wrong so that
you're prepared for it
like when i went into it i was like oh
yeah this is so going to work and this
is amazing this idea is great and let's
do this and let's do that
and um money went out but like money did
not come back i was not prepared for
them to actually fail i was like
what they didn't do well okay no that's
that's crazy
so and and because of that not being
prepared for it i was like my whole exit
or i was not like covered at all
so i think that's important maybe keep
your legal
invest in legal if anything and um
always be prepared for it to go because
it's a risk right so it could go either
way
always be prepared for it to go like in
a
completely different direction yeah i
would
i don't know if you have any other
advice i think like it'd be great for
young entrepreneurs to actually hear
that as well because it really sucks you
know when you put so much time and money
into something and then it doesn't work
out and you're like
you know it's like right away and you're
just like i don't need a contract
they're nice
yeah no biggest you do
you do anybody is saying is true they're
willing to put it on paper and if
they're not willing to put it on paper
it's not true
absolutely absolutely it's always fair
right so
you've yeah but yeah it's important
what was what i don't know have you ever
been through losses yet
or anything like that lessons
what's one lesson you would say you've
learned in business
that you would tell a young little
whippersnapper
like enough that you make sure you like
the people you're doing business with
yeah but yeah for sure because you're
stuck with them kind of
until yeah make sure that you
because like or or make sure their
character is good because like you can
be like oh business is thriving
and all of a sudden they get like a rape
case and then
associated or you have uh what's that
clause
in a contract it's um a clause that if
it's a morality clause so if you do
something that
like if your partner does something
that's just like like
he's a mass murderer or something then
you could easily get him out of the
company and
like get rid of him yeah i mean like
so about about liking the person or the
people that you're working with
a lot of the times business changes a
lot
of equations so like you could sometimes
even be getting into business with your
family and
then be like i don't know after you
start the business like things like
equations change things change you're
not happy with the way that person's
performing
but how do you tell them so it's like
more than that i think like you've just
gotta
like everyone's just gotta be super
clear from the beginning like this is
what you need to be doing
this is like your your your role and
this is what you have to perform at
and and if if not then you're just going
against the claws or you're going
against the contract and there will be
circumstances or
there will be you know um i mean you
you you'd have to own up to that so
because i don't know if you've
experienced that but
people people do change during business
i mean like you've seen families fall
apart you've seen
friendships fall apart um things do
change when pressure hits or like
there's stress
um you know it's it can get difficult
like on a lot of people so
yeah i think uh just i'm in business
with both of you i'm in business with
batch and i'm in business with uh
jacqueline what is one thing that you
guys
can say about doing business with me
you'll get it oh my god
yeah i can just get it relax
[Laughter]
like no you can't
[Laughter]
can't find me i'm gonna
[Laughter]
no but i i love this and i'm i swear to
god by the end of this year i i'm you
know
i'm going to learn so much from amanda
there is such professionalism
like which is like you would you're like
the ideal business partner
the ideal business partner you're
professional you're clear you're
super hard-working unlike everything you
put your mind to
and i saw this when you came down to
india as well i'm seeing that now on the
podcast and that's like
the you know the key ingredient to like
to to any successful business
um and you're so motivating like it's
like it's so inspiring like the way you
work
and like how you work and you know just
you're uh you're so systematic
it's insane i am right
you are it's like it's amazing though
like how
uh everything is always in place and in
order so
like and and and it's like and it's fun
as well like there's like there's like
you know there's a lovely light energy
to it so
it's amazing yay
mutual for me i mean you guys kind of
like balance me out
which is good um because i am
so like yeah
you guys are just like hey
levitating you guys are floating
[Laughter]
that's it i'm starting morning drinking
from next week well i think we can move
on to our next fun fact
did you know why isn't that oh
why don't you read this one actually you
read this one while i use the restroom
okay ooh
someone's had a bit too much to drink um
okay you're right i think our number
seven
seven twitter ceo
dick castolos used to work as an improv
comedian
he got a gig with the famous improv
group second city oh very famous yeah
and later another one at the annoyance
theater
he did it for years wow
he's a twitter ceo wow
comedian wow i love that though
so he has like this great light side to
him oh wow i can hear you crazy close
now
what's up what's up
wait like how did i still understand
were you picking up my
volume from when her mic like how are
you even picking up my voice
oh from these headphones wow they're
that loud
yeah they're really loud that is crazy
that was a nice quick one amanda that
was about
could you hear me it just flew out and
efficient
[Music]
i waste no time
[Music]
oh my god or did we hate it oh it was a
great one
the twitter ceo used to be a comedian he
did like stand up
huh oh and that's what batch does too
what don't you do
i'll make when you're wow do not
i don't know how you do stand up i i'm
it it mortifies me i would never
be able to go up on stage and do
standard never say never you could do it
no i could not do that oh my god no no
wait i could go off on stage and dance
and find like thousands i would
need to see you do it see oh my god
you already got your first you already
got your first audience man good pain i
would laugh at every joke
even oh my god you better laugh
i feel like that's like the number one
thing um your friends that are stand-ups
want you to do is just to go and then
tell him later hey
another one i mean that never happens
with him i actually haven't been to one
of your shows i'm a horror
friend oh wouldn't you know if she was
there
like yeah
they're out of la they're like in utah
ohio
oh my gosh like what's
what is something that people love
laughing i mean like what's one thing
that always gets people like what topic
what do they love hearing about diets oh
like they find that funny yeah just
because everyone struggles with it
yeah it's relatable uh relationships oh
relationships is number one the best
relationships
um about experiences everyone everyone
wants to hear an experience
yeah that's true actually and i think
like there's there's
for free a personality where can they go
come on
why don't you come down to india and do
a stand up it'll be so much fun
it would be massive if you went yeah
yeah it would be back open jacqueline
and i would be your backup dancers
yeah oh i have to do like a no you just
well you can perform and we'll be the
backup dancers
like every time you like you you hit a
joke we'll come and be like
we'll just like yeah and then we'll just
slide out and you can move on to your
next joke you know
you do really well i feel like yeah yeah
oh yes so yes yeah we could just yeah
but totally though
i think it would be really fun i think
um whenever you guys get some
me and amanda have already had i think
we've like we're to visit like seven
countries we've made plans
so we're just adding this one yeah yeah
we have about seven countries
doing this podcast with you i can't tell
you how many dms from casting agents
and producers i've gotten for like
bollywood stuff
[Music]
so she you're i'm telling you by next
year amanda's in a bollywood film
she is a bollywood film
[Music]
it has to be with you oh but we
we actually had a very cool concept for
something that we want to do together
and hopefully we will be putting that
together soon
[Music]
i'll be the number one fan
[Applause]
there we go you can just like you can
write it do you write your
um like like do you write stuff do you
write your scenes or do you write
your yeah my youtube stuff yeah
i mean like you could be one of our like
help us with the writing as well
oh i've never wrote a movie before but i
saw a batch
um working on directing oh yeah
lately i think you'd be amazing yeah
directing academy yeah but i like i like
you both to do this by the way
jacqueline you do this
batch you do this anytime there's
something that
you want to pursue you heavily
study it and learn to learn the craft
to perfection before you pursue it on
your own
you have to true before you go and make
because even with you jacqueline when
she came to
l.a like we were doing dancing classes
she had like all of her language stuff
like you know
like every day she was in some type of
class oh really
yeah yeah what language are you learning
well
i mean no actually so basically when i
came to
india i couldn't speak a word of hindi
so
now like i continuously keep like
learning it and practicing it and
reading it and like
um it just because it just improves
because it's not my first language but i
act in hindi
it just improves um can people tell
you are they like oh she's american get
her out of here
no but they they are like she has an
accent
yeah yeah i mean like because my accent
just
it's really it it's hard for me to
to master but
yeah it's it's completely the opposite
of english it's completely like
to everything like the word the sentence
formation like
as like a simple thing like i love you
like in in hindi becomes
i you love so like the i the two
object like the two so i and you always
come together
the verb of what you're doing comes last
so and like even like so if something is
like
yeah say what how do you say it
so i you love do
like that also comes that's so long yeah
so like it's like the formation and
that's what i found to be difficult as
well the formation is like completely
because like if i think in english and i
try and translate it it doesn't it
doesn't work
so you've gotta kind of be you know as
comfortable with thinking
in hindi as well like thinking in the
language so that it comes out in more of
a flow the minute i try to think in
english and like translate i'm like oh
wait wait that doesn't go there that
goes
sure so but yeah so it's um
luckily though in hindi films we get to
dub everything
so the entire film we go back in the
studio and we redub
like we just dub all the lines again wow
really
it's tiring like a lot of people hate it
because like obviously the emotion that
you get even in your voice
when you're on live location is amazing
why do they make you guys do that
so basically what happens is there is an
issue with
sound um and uh
like a lot of times see stuff is
there there are quite a few movies right
now that have just they've left that
whole
process of dubbing and they're like no
we're gonna do sing sound and
but it's like in bombay when you're
shooting there's always some noise i'm
like our sets
are like crowded like there are a lot of
people
like i mean it's just because of like
certain rules and this like each light
man that
like each light has like seven light man
light light men
uh i don't even think of that that's
there's a lot of people so like
inevitably there's like some sound
happening there's some footprint of
someone sneezing there's some
something happening so uh the sound is
never crystal clear
and um but yeah but a lot of like yeah a
lot of films are working towards
just completely eradicating um dubbing
right now
i get this when i gotta go in and dub
like two lines i'm like come on do we
really need these two lines cut them out
the film
yeah that's me no
the screaming like everything we go back
in
and a lot of actors what they do is
because like they're so used to that now
they correct they actually make it
better they'll like correct it
they'll like they'll you know put more
into the voice or they'll you know
so um yeah but there are like
yeah it is in a way to just redo the
performance for me it really helps
because i'm like yes i get to work on my
addiction now like or i get to work on
the way i pronounce that
i pronounce that really badly you know
but a lot of i mean a lot of actors hate
it as well they're just like [ __ ] like
how do
i replicate that now so it's tough i
mean
we're between both worlds right now but
it's great to know that you have an
option though
is a lot of is all filming done in india
or is it
like is some done in like europe or yeah
oh yeah
you bounce around to different locations
but i feel like oh yeah yeah yeah
and i mean our studios are all here yeah
we use all the studios from here
uh but if we need outdoor locations and
in a lot of our films like we love
seeing outdoor locations it just opens
up a film
like it takes us out of india um so we
do travel quite a bit like london
is super popular for our film
switzerland used to like
literally be like i mean everyone in
switzerland knows about bollywood
because
so many films were shot there in the 90s
it was like like super famous
like the bollywood stars were actually
like superstars in switzerland
because like the amount of films yeah
the amount of films i got shot there
i love it i love
it it's crazy how like you know i think
maybe platforms like streaming platforms
are changing that a little bit more how
people are consuming
content from if it's like a bollywood
production like
it's easier to access it now if you're
in the us
but more people are getting exposed to
that culture
like i i love it like i try to like and
introduce it as much as i can because
it's like it's
it's so cool it's like it really makes
the whole world just
like i know fun yes
i don't even know if there's like a
hollywood or a bollywood anymore because
with everything i agree
kind of meshing into one i agree
it's like you know just the fact that
also like people reach out to you right
to be in like bollywood films right
or like even hollywood uses like chinese
actors or
you know indian actors or like so many
people mexicans like
it's just that like now everything's
embraced like so many different cultures
cinema has embraced
and because of like ott platforms it's
like
honestly like people in india are
watching french films korean films
american films like everyone's watching
everything like i was watching
korean a korean show yesterday i'm
watching like a lot of turkish cinema
so it's like all of a sudden cinema
there was a time where it was just
hollywood or
or maybe it was just bollywood for for
certain people now it's like
there's everything there's like i know
so many different actors it's crazy
because like i watch so many
korean tv shows i like i actually know
like oh that actor was on that show oh
that actor was like i actually
like really know them now like and i've
discovered some
unbelievable actors like in turkish
cinema who are like so
good like europeans like it's
belgium has some crazy cinema as well so
it's like
and that's the thing like people are
also boring borrowing different actors
from
all over the world which i love there's
so many different cultures now like in
you know and different content so
i think it's great everyone's moving
around now and doing like different
things
it's opening up yeah
finally it's about time
yeah about time for sure i think we
what we can probably do now i think
we've been going for quite a while we
can jump to the questions from
fans yay one of them is
how many pets do you own between all of
you i got one
i got one i got four cats
[Laughter]
six
sex math
i'm good at it all right what is your
favorite joke
um relationships
[Music]
yeah favorite joke
i'm really bad at jokes guys i don't
know any i don't have a favorite joke
favorite joke i don't either
i don't even have a favorite song
yeah i i feel like also with jokes it's
more about the way the person says it
and
like the you know what i mean like more
than specifically
performance yeah you know that kind of
makes it funny or especially if it's
like someone you
know or like something that's like
happening like the situation
and and when people kind of trip and
fall
i find that really funny you like the
english comedy
it's just really crazy
it's really funny when someone's kind
but like
fear is like skiing or someone falls on
their bum i just find it really funny
what's that the fake slop i don't know
how to do it
oh i love it and
go
[Music]
oh god
oh my god amazing it was acting guys
that was oh my god but that should be
that should be our teaser
amanda gets slapped and disclaimer you
never deserve it
leave right away
all that good stuff always disclaimer
that was a great scratch lab what is in
your pocket or your purse right now you
don't have a purse i'm at home
do you what's in it probably some
condoms
[Music]
no i'm just kidding there's nothing in
my pockets
easy access ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls
hello never know bigger those holes
know what i mean
red wine or white wine as long as it's
six two six
idk roses
sorry english isn't my first language
i don't know i love that brother as long
as it's 6 26
i don't know i have no idea
but you know what it was so cool that
the way you said it i actually didn't
realize what you said i was like
wow that's all about how you say it it's
the delivery
exactly i wish you were here so you
could drink some of this
i know i feel like coffee right now is
so super important
ready for me yeah
this is so sweet
[Music]
oh my god i'm gonna down this
[Music]
whoa was amazing
it hit me thank you
just downed it yeah i'm drunk
all right drunk already couldn't you
live without
what food couldn't i live without
uh fruits
fruit sushi you know
i kind of got over sushi
but even like i could live without it i
love
sushi that used to be
everything to me and 11 years ago i
became vegan
and maybe 12 years ago
a fun story about batch no no
what what oh yeah poisoned her
yeah you poisoned her why
okay i'm gonna tell it really quick
sounds scary yeah jacqueline do you want
to hear it or
i'm yeah i do but i'm yeah maury oh okay
right now you're sitting next to him
yeah and
that's all the time we have today folks
thanks for tuning in
and there we go oh wait i know where
this is going okay i would say
fruit is what i would miss
by the way just you saying amsterdam
gave enough away
we got it we got it guys
what is
[Laughter]
okay yeah that's fine i thought you took
my uh
no oh there's another one now you have
to tell that one
okay tell me later then i want to know
yeah okay what was the other one
um the one okay we were in amsterdam and
it was like
late we just went to our friend's show
and so we're hungry
um and then i can't read anything in
dutch
and it's how it's random like i don't
know and then
we went to we were at the hotel and they
had like this whole
like shop and this is in the middle of
us doing like prank wars we're doing
like prank wars oh yeah
oh my god wow that sounds like fun
no we should not do that i definitely
wonder
words by the way yeah you lose my number
[Laughter]
anyways so we are in amsterdam and then
he
i was hungry and then he was like oh let
me make get this pasta let me make this
pasta and then he made it
and then i was eating it i'm like it
kind of tastes like um
mud like
like throw up like oh
gross and i'm like i took one bite and i
swallowed it i'm like um i took another
bite just to see and i remember that
i remember and i was like please tell me
it was not oh my god
what it was uh what was it bolognese
yeah and i've been vegan for like
my whole life
[Music]
i've been vegan my whole life and then
been thinking for a long time and then
he tricked me with pulling it yeah
is that a ghost did you see him
jacqueline my breakfast
killed what did you get for breakfast um
what did i
oh oh my god i got some pancakes
oh damn you eating good girl
i got some pancakes i got some
berries oh i got some jam
i love you guys you're like
i'll eat breakfast
last question what is something that
makes you guys smile every day
uh my work
my dog oh
yeah i want to change mine um
my cats so that's the difference between
cat people and dog people
dog people get real love yeah from the
dogs and then the cat people just like
have a roommate yeah dogs like love you
but when but when they give love
it's so cute it's like cuter
nicer yes i'm allergic all right
so the winner announcement of our cash
prize giveaway
why isn't batch announce it oh good okay
huh yeah
announce our winner for the week oh so
this is a winner announcement
and this is what they wrote on their
review to win the cash prize
and then that's what you read ladies and
gentlemen oh wait just ladies
yeah because we're two girls and now
it's you so you can say ladies and match
ladies and badge it's wonderful to hear
the back end stories of celebrities i
love your messages
that all voices matter jackie looking
forward to your five
upcoming movies five whoa
slow down baby girl eight looking
forward to your eight upcoming movies
and hearing about
on the podcast global girls
winner winner is that with this pocket
global girls no that's not no oh
i used to read it
congratulations thanks for leaving us a
five star review on apple podcast
keep leaving us positive five star
reviews and you could
win some money honey so moving on
we're all about here to tell you i don't
know what i'm saying
jack let me do that if you simply want
to feel good and listen you can follow
feels good on spotify or podcast one or
anywhere you want to listen podcast
thank you so much for listening see you
next tuesday
you sexy wait dude
yes oh my god that's crazy you
got censored as the minute you said that
on my side
it blew yeah no i just went you said no
yeah thank you so much for listening see
you next tuesday you sexy [ __ ]
there we go again thanks for listening
see you next tuesday you sexy
[ __ ]
is it doing it yeah
thanks so much for listening see you
next tuesday you sexy mothers
[Laughter]
bye love you guys
we won oh my god